hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay I'm making
our way through here is a chasm I can't
jump okay easy hey whoa hey hey don't no
no don't try
not even a little bit gone
hey Oh Amy's still a little funky with
this gun but you know it's okay I'm
liking it a little more get out of here
yeah I'm another stasis [ __ ] Wow
I never need to get his stasis recharge
packed ever if there's gonna be this
matter I remember you
save me--save gimme gimme gimme gimme
all right I'll looping back again okay I
don't think I'll ever need to go back I
mean I haven't been close to dying I
don't know if there's an autosave system
it would really suck
cuz it is a bit of a distance in between
the save points if there's no autosave
function and that's back that's bad
there's writing on the walls here
the marker will save us put it back put
it back wha where bip-bip I don't know I
can't read that what are you willing to
give up your life for oh I don't know
never been asked that question whoa hey
hey
to hell oh I'm in a vacuum okay
oh that's what the ear is sure okay
thank you really
okay shouldn't be able to hear myself
okay okay
stuff I don't know what that was but
it's something okay all right it's got a
boy hello body kind of sucked to be us
hmm as you know the Jamuna is able to
set his gravity locusts
I did not know that brutal kick is when
you enter a zero-g area okay
did not know that whatever
ha okay
impressive I'm impressed you impressed
me have any control hell yeah
animal counter will flash red if you can
tell me service
okay how do I jump face nope I didn't
look I wasn't paying attention
you know Z C okay wasted that be F
oh hello oh these are it's cloudy grab
up sorry dead guy kubu I brought you to
place them okay their mantra okay I was
not paying attention shift control Oh
control okay there we go
wow that's disorienting gimme gimme
gimme
why can't you round a corner is it
really that much oh wow this is oh this
is disorienting okay okay come here come
here come here
good in there yep
oh so smart so smart and so cute ah okay
what did I get great you got a shock bad
so I combined that with the thermite at
the barricade to destroy it
you mean like it if you were I can later
me walking through the vents yeah say
visor
I won't don't tell me what to do put
myself in danger come here come here oh
you're gonna regret that boom
you're gonna regret that
ah mo regret is something I having great
quantities for blinds this gun
are you dead die oh my god anything this
gun is so useless it's so useless
yeah he's gone is the worst oh man it is
here why is there three of these things
why do there need to be three I don't
know
oh hello kami useless Brown Street no
not why isn't the space button jump okay
let me do a few video
Wow maybe cuz
alright I'll still admit though I didn't
mention this but for an older game the
graphics in this game are phenomenal
really I know it's not an ancient game
but it's one of the early Xbox games I
think so it's really good
Hey Oh Oh cuz in space no one can hear
you scream
okay that's pretty cool I wonder why I
didn't hear laughing not say oh that's
pretty
hello hi there okay alright
oh hey no no no no full-auto up and up
stop e you oh yeah oh so much
ownage someone wants some more dudes I'm
not even gonna bother to save I don't
need to wait am I going the right way
okay yeah over here
oh so strong move that with my brain I
don't know how that works
Wow hey
we like to jump out at people Donna
squish hi where are you oh I'm not down
there it's so stupid
okay I'm getting better at shooting off
the limbs it's just that this pulse
rifle is not designed to cut off limbs
like the plasma cutter is I should have
known that I should have known that but
I'm just so stupid
I don't know anything wait what
item yep yeah I'm just sticking with the
plasma I'm gonna sell back the assault
rifle
oh I wasted a power note on it I'm an
idiot
I opened this I had a key power note
card there must be something good in
here
right okay huh a wasted one power node
why not waste another is it safe no
obviously it is not okay that seems
worth it Oh big medpac did you find
something down there didn't you yes we
found something so the texts were right
all this I wouldn't be certain of that
there was nothing divined in what I saw
you are some bracelet we are the first
witness us the thighs isn't something
anyone down on the colony it's under
quarantine until we learn more well with
Mathias he of all people should know
that this is greater than him hold
operation or even the company this is
our deliverance you can voice down
people are dying down here only the
worthless and the unbelievers but I
believe do you please - no do you know
ya don't believe okay there's a crazy
religious fanatic okay token crazy
religious fanatic okay yeah you're the
guy to kill it Jeff
recharge whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa hey
what the heck II hacky-sack what are you
oh damn
what are you holy crap
Oh get get get oh good good good
hey ah hey get off of me
Tommy smash the e button I kiss Massey
button ah hey don't stop don't don't
don't
BAM nah miss wasting so much ammo that
would that's why I get the assault rifle
Oh cuz I can kill those things I should
have done that
I heard her home
sounded like an item I thought it was
okay store sell some crap like my stasis
charge I don't need any of them
pulse rounds okay okay um I don't need
two large red packs oh that's a lot of
credits gold semiconductor valuable
electrons solid store for credits okay
why couldn't you just give me money why
does it need to be here air canister I
can't even imagine needing that say
speck get out of the same spot okay
shop see I can get pulse rounds but I
don't need to oh I can buy power notes
uh seems like a good deal but I'm gonna
hold off again I'm gonna hold off on
buying stuff until I know exactly what I
need because who knows like the assault
rifle I now know a use for it I can use
it to you know go through stuff okay for
my buck term I bought thermite whoa
okay stand right next to it when it goes
off that's smart okay I am going to cut
it here thank you guys so much for
watching as always I appreciate every
single one of you so I will see you in
the next part
bye bye